it looks good it's a nice color do you
get beautiful in that I'm putting this
on what you can't back out I am NOT
gonna wear two dresses in a span of like
three weeks on YouTube so here's the
thing Matt played a 2v1 against me and
Jenna and hardpoint on Call of Duty and
he lost you lost we got to pick what you
do since I have to jump in the pool with
my clothes on from losing I want to be
one with Matt I said okay you jump in
the pool with my clothes on hey we still
need something a punishment for Jenna's
channel though so you guys can leave you
some comments let us know what you think
one punishment you guys play one team
you get one punishment I feel don't
there's no I in team
unless you're I just see ya okay just
put it on I think it's he's making it
way more of a big deal than it really is
like a really tight dress I mean I'm
really eager to see what it looks like
and everyone's gonna misinterpret that
comment let's wait and see how's it
going in there
I don't want to see what's there yet I'm
not ready
Oh better news on me right
uh it's not there I could hit the town
right now yeah this is like easy season
for Connie Neeson call me up I'd like to
do a side-by-side comparison of me
wearing this dress and then Matt so
please hold
okay there we go there's Matt okay here
we go
no you gotta jump in the first come on I
get to push you in let's bring some
towels out for ya good idea
so who's going in first now I was very
very scared
go go go all right cool right now it's
like five just go for it
no I'm not you gotta go all at once you
gotta jump in it I'm gonna catch you all
get in the pool tiptoe above the water I
promise you didn't drown congratulate
8-ball oh my god oh I wasn't filming
what was it working we're gonna hear are
you sir I can't swim I haven't done this
in so long just fix the [__] what you
doing
it is not deep the boys are upset with
me Jordan it's not that bad advertised
the heated pool itch in the 80s dude ha
never lose another game of call duty as
long as I live
this is good motivation rookie oh right
this is great lighting it is really good
could you really not swim I think I'm I
think I can swim yeah I took a young
Michael Phelps yeah you are both more
attractive and more muscle and for dress
I mean Michael Phelps has never looked
so good
fit ring the bell ring the bell ring the
bell ring the bell good boy it was funny
he was really hungry